[Musique]
dans le nord ça va mal la surprise c'est
que ça va plus mal qu'à lyon
[Musique]
en 1967 le chômage a doublé l on en
croit deux cas les cinquante mille
travailleurs chiffres officiels le nord
et sept pour cent des travailleurs de
france et 12 % des chômeurs de france
c'est une surprise comme en or cette
région pilote cette espèce de roue en 16
at il pu en arriver là et bien
simplement parce que les trois
industries de base qui ont fait la
richesse de cette région charbon de
textile la sidérurgie en font maintenant
sinon la pauvreté du moins apporte la
menace d'une décadence progressive le
nord s'était tranquillement endormi
depuis des lustres sur cet art charbon
de l'aisne et d'acier ce réveil brutal
[Musique]
vrai drame c'est la fermeture des mines
de charbon parce que c'est irréversible
un puits de mine fermée et ne rouvrira
jamais dans la région ouest les lignes à
béthune depuis 1950 les puits ferme
maintenant que ces puits sont fermés
c'est la fin d'une époque
[Musique]
pour les mineurs c'est plus que de
l'amertume d'abord c'est leur métier est
en jeu ensuite c'est à ses hommes après
la libération que l'on avait dit
extrayez du charbon pour la renaissance
française c'était un slogan lui quand
ils ont bien travaillé et maintenant ils
n'ont pas l'impression d'être tellement
les compenser
[Musique]
jusqu'ici les houillères entreprises
nationalisées ont évité les
licenciements proprement dit on fusionne
les effectifs dont les regroupent sur
les puits les plus modernes comme celui
d'oignies voici
plus de cinq mille mineurs une
mécanisation très poussé une meilleure
rentabilité dans l'extraction du charbon
oignies extrait 15 mille tonnes de
charbon par jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fosse 5 à loos en gohelle va bientôt
fermer ça va fermer
alors vous allez faire la faire comme
tout le monde j'ai loupé entre voulez
vous y faire qu'est ce qui va se passer
c'est chaud plutôt chic hodan arriver là
notre force que je dois faire
alors va être muté on va ajouter méduses
ses proches et choc est inquiétant quand
j'ai vu que ça va finir match pour finir
avec jardinet de javols seshoka passe
toute façon s'il a asséché faut
simplement pas nous avons travaillé là
bas biribi il faut bien nous donner une
plage focale de pair j'ai déjà fait la
france 3 noeuds j'ai fait la pause 6 de
mazagan la pause ne ça fait trois fois
que je fais dans six ans alors j'en
pensais nous demandons qu est-ce qui va
remplacer les mines parce qu'une mène à
l'occupent david x 800 900 mhz au nord
tandis que vous avez des usines qui et
qui emploie 60 70 bonhomme et on se
demande qu'est ce qu'on va faire de nos
enfants cachent allez-vous 53 ans
pensionnaire oui il ya trois ans que
j'ai pris mon autre
métier ou fauve en 36 langues faut alors
comment ça se transmet
par acheteur je me suis sorti de
l'ornière sera vôtre mais j'ai macho il
vient de partir à l'armée quand il va
rentrer ce qu'il va retrouver bien rien
de prévu pour les gosses et qui c'est
qui est responsable et touchant j'ai
bien fermé les fausses mais on aurait dû
prévenir du boulot pour les jeunes on ne
réduit implanter des usines tout partout
qu'est ce qu'on va faire je n'ai corac
saison et à l'école quand tu veux quand
je lis vos carrelage et de travailler y
a rien pour lui je mets ça ça ils
bourrique tête où ils saboter tout est
votre six étaient d'accord pour aller à
la mine lui mais sûrement on est mineur
et de père à fils
tout le monde il ya passé d'alphaville
mais aujourd'hui on arrive à un point
n'y a rien il n'y a plus rien on préfère
elle laissait pourtant au fond des mines
et du charbon mais on dit ça va trop
cher pour l'exploiter
on est à l'étranger les transitions moi
c'est si on vous dit bah c'est la
reconversion il faut trouver un autre
métier sont bien obligés pour vie font
oublier recherchez un métier qu'est ce
que vous avez comme qualification bon
sens et pas de certificat d'études
savez paris 6 et
s'élimine alors les pères édiles péridy
bon ben htira aux mines comme moi est ce
que vous aimeriez changer de métier
c'est pas courant sachez liminaire bas
et péter
je crois que si j'avais une formation
professionnelle ocre et doré j'aimerais
faire enfin
j'aime bien la technique que
l'automobile si vous arrivez à changer
de métier voudriez rester dans le nord
pourquoi le départ ici on connaît tout
le monde
on connaît toute la région ont préféré
c'est par ici
[Musique]
oui le mineur est attaché à son corps on
que des gens trouvent tellement laid est
attaché à son point de jardin sa terre à
sa maison
monsieur gosselin vous êtes venu inviter
grenelle pour être plus près de votre
appareil
vous a demandé la maison ici j'ai
demandé à la maison il a fallu que
j'attende six mois comme il ya deux
pièces dans la maison cird 1,5
j'en ai j'ai deux chambres à
aubière cuisine d'ici
salle à manger p1 bien su côté là on a
notre charbon auto show mine tout ça
mais un bon show von hebel cheminée tous
à ce que maintenant savoir vous y tenez
à la maison ah ouais c'est
ça peut presser chine c'est notre chez
nous quoi et si on vous dit d'avis en
hlm
là ça serait différent c'est pas le goût
de tout le monde
premièrement c'est
même bien avant les pieds sur un terrain
il ya combien de temps vous êtes mariés
je me suis mariée il ya quinze ans
j'ai quatre enfants chantal profite à
quercia chantage ou elle patrick et
sylvie votre femme travaille donc
emménagé ici le travail à combien vous
gagnez par mois monsieur gosselin on n'a
pas de prix fixe
à peu près 50 50 mille francs par
quinzaine cinquante cinq mille avec les
allocations
et savary ça peut aller jusqu'à combien
370 les la télévision bien sûr oui
monsieur la plupart des mineurs lors à
wisches et 98% après c'est faux parce
que tous les mineurs vous avez une
voiture oui monsieur voiture d'occasion
à occasions comme meilleur moyen quoi
vous avez été moniteur
j'ai fait des stages de moniteurs oui
j'ai passé décès à payer tout ça j'ai
réussi il me dit plante alors j'allais
jouer avec des enfants des mines les
enfants de mines l'effet du skimming oui
oui je vais faire du ski on était dans
tir l'autriche arrêtée en suisse
dans les hautes-alpes en voyant son côté
de briançon tous avec les jeunes mineurs
les jeunes du centre d'apprentissage
qu'est ce que vous faites de vos
vacances
de mes vacances mais trois semaines de
vacances que j'ai on va camper avec des
amis mais c'est 3,4 km de berck connaît
c'est tout près de la mer ah oui trois
kilomètres de la mer n'est pas tellement
loin
km le bélier en principe quand il fait
bon parce que tous les jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y à un autre péril les houillères du
nord et du pas de calais c'est d'une
sorte d' empire elles possèdent leurs
propres centrales électriques par
exemple ils fournissent le réseau
française que l'on ignore ne possède pas
du tout uniquement des mines
propriétaire de 120 mille logements du
sinn mêmes d'église elles sont l'un des
plus gros propriétaire foncier france
potentiel technique outre les mineures
quelques 1000 ingénieurs 6000 agents de
maîtrise et si c'est énorme potentiel
devait disparaître ce serait un terrible
appauvrissement collège
[Musique]
bon monsieur mandat est ce que c'est
vraiment la fin du charbon oui et non
pour le bassin du nord et du
pas-de-calais
il est vrai que nous n'avons plus ou
plus fière de charbon dans l'ouest il
livra il est vrai aussi que le charme
monde l'est du bassin la région de
valenciennes et de doué par contre s'il
y en a encore et beaucoup et l'objet de
la concurrence du fioul du gaz et
d'électricité par contre dans le centre
du bassin c'est à dire dans la région
d'hénin liétard et de lens nous avons là
des charbons à coke
et c'est charbon à coke sont encore
indispensables
à l'industrie à la sidérurgie française
pour assurer sa sécurité son
indépendance
et
je souhaite que nous extrayons ce
charbon mais jusqu'à sa dernière tu il
reste tout de même encore pas mal de
charbon
est une source importante d'énergie
nation surnom est ce que c'est pas
dangereux de la boucler cette source
d'énergie le fioul c'est très joli mais
si ce report d'une chose comme la crise
de suez par exemple qu'est ce qu'on fait
là monsieur mandat oui bien sûr les
pluies dont ils sont fermés ils sont
fermés ils sont fermés définitivement
fermé et c'est évidemment dangereux mais
enfin il ya des belges et l impératif
économique qui joue là aussi je ne suis
pas le seul juge c'est au gouvernement
de juger un sujet je comprends
parfaitement bien que
le gouvernement n'avait pas pénaliser
l'économie française avec des prix de
l'énergie trop élevé
mais ceci dit je pense aussi que le
gouvernement doit tenir compte des
considérations sociales
sinon économique d'une récession taux
rapide du charbon je pense en
particulier que nous pouvons encore
utiliser notre charbon dans les
centrales thermiques
et à ce sujet nous souhaitons construire
encore dans la bassin du nord et pas de
calais une deux ou peut être trois
centrales thermiques au charbon
appartenant à rouyère brûlant le charbon
des houillères du nord pas de calais
je crois qu'on peut dire que grâce aux
houillères la récession de charbon se
fait au moins en bon ordre pour le
moment vous pour le moment tout se passe
bien mais le problème voyez vous c'est
pas tellement le problème charbon pour
moi tout au moins si le problème des
hommes mais je me rends à on dit que les
houillères s'en vont sur la pointe des
pieds ah mais non on les houillères ne
sont pas du tout les houillères se
transforme
nous faisons moins de charbon mais par
contre nous utilisons dans les pas des
pratiques que nous produisons pour en
faire un peu tous les bateaux
nous essayons d'utiliser nos matières
plastiques nous étudions le problème de
l'utilisation de la carte classique dans
le bâtiment et avec succès pour vraiment
et nous faisons les containers maison un
peu tout dépôt dia route aussi nous
utilisons oui des boudaoud et ne pourra
pas cela entre les ouvriers et dans de
bonnes conditions
nous avons un potentiel considérable et
ses potentiels n'avons pas l'intention
de gaspiller et nous le mettons à
disposition de notre diversification est
aussi à disposition de la région
[Musique]
dans la sambre ça ne va pas tellement
bien non plus maubeuge déplore son
isolement au buzz je voudrais que canal
de la sambre soit élargie pour la
navigation
[Musique]
maubeuge est devenue une ville très
moderne doté d'un remarquable lycée
classique et aussi d'un lycée technique
mais maubeuge se demande où iront ces
diplômés pour trouver du travail
[Musique]
e
et que le bassin de la sambre est l'un
des plus touchés au nord entre maubeuge
et au loin des usines sont fermées c'est
dû à une mauvaise conjoncture dans les
industries mécaniques et la sidérurgie
[Musique]
mais
certes tout ne va pas mal vallourec et
ses tubes tourner et forgeant dire moi
aussi mais il y a un grave problème dans
la sidérurgie à usinor et laminoirs ne
seront pas fermées et laminoirs vont
rester mais quel problème des hauts
fourneaux plutôt du haut fourneau le
haut fourneau de louvroil récent va
fermer cette année victimes la mutation
de l'industrie vers la mer et si le
froid le ferme c'est qu'à dunkerque le
même usinor s'est installé ici le
minerai plus riches venus une mauritanie
est utilisée directement sans transport
supplémentaires sans rupture de charge
coûteuses comme on l'est dans
l'industrie
dans son usine modèle de dunkerque deux
fourneaux peuvent produire 5500 tonnes
de fonte par jour liant un troisième en
construction le voici et celui-là pourra
produire autant que les deux autres
réunies
il ya une situation difficile dans la
sidérurgie
par exemple dans cet immense hall où
notre dame et c'est tout pourrait tenir
à un mètre près on le voit pratiquement
plus personne tout est automatisé
meilleure productivité aux animateurs
à roubaix tourcoing les anciennes
vizille du textile affectionne les
styles étrange ils vont du gothique aux
néo mauresque on reste soutenue ou
encore hostile donjon et dynastique ce
sont là les citadelles d'un esprit
encore présents
l'esprit des premières industries du
nord au type familial ces industries qui
sont nés au moment de la révolution
industrielle de la fin du 19e siècle
lorsque le charbon et la vapeur firent
la richesse de la région
bon eh bien vous êtes deux générations
de la société au legends thibérienne le
père et le fils c'est une entreprise au
fond typiquement familial et qui je
pense a très bien réussi c'est pas
toujours le cas
évidemment je crois que les entreprises
familiales doivent être considérés parmi
les meilleurs et elles doivent être
considérés parmi les meilleurs parce que
elles permettent un contact très humain
entre la direction et le personnel
il se passe pas je puis dire de jour
où l'un ou l'autre viennent frapper à la
porte de mon bureau pour exposer encore
son cas particulier
et les difficultés qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer
mais ce qu'il faut pour que les
entreprises familiales continue à vivre
c'est que ces entreprises familiales ce
disciple et qu'elle établisse une
structure où le principe d'autorité soit
parfaitement reconnue par l'ensemble des
associés quand vous dites
les associés reconnaissent une autorité
l'autorité d'un seul dans la famille
d'un seul dans la famille d'un associé
certaines de ces entreprises familiales
certainement n'ont pas su se sucent se
structurer comme je le disais tout à
l'heure et la catastrophe est arrivée
sur roubaix tour à vous employer on
vient de sauver pourquoi nous employons
deux mille trois cents ouvriers employés
cadres
et en totalité aux entreprises à
l'étranger il faut compter environ 4500
ou y
comment est-ce que ça se décompose à
l'étranger il s'est fondé des filiales à
l'étranger en belgique en hollande en
angleterre et même au début 2009 150 en
afrique du sud - le chômage il y a un
peu de chômage total un millier de
personnes il y a également du chômage
partiel se sont massés partiel est lié à
la structure saisonnières de beaucoup de
nos productions et je demande à monsieur
tigana fils
il me parle un petit peu de la crise du
textile je pense qu'il est bon de
rappeler que par exemple la note chine
qui était un débouchés considérables
pour l'industrie cotonnière a disparu
que à la suite des événements
relativement récent c'est l'afrique du
nord qui a pratiquement disparu il y a
également l'afrique noire qui disparaît
chaque jour davantage il faut signaler
d'ailleurs aussi n'est ce pas que la
mode est de plus en plus fluctuantes et
par conséquent nous oblige à des
changements de fabrication qui sont
extrêmement importants deux fois par an
est ce que vous avez pensé de la
minijupe
là mais je l'habille du jeu est bien la
minuk nous attendons en fait que la mode
change est entendue hélas
hélas parce que la consommation tissu
s'en trouve affectée c'est simple mais
il y a un grand espoir derrière la
minijupe en ce sens que lorsque la mode
en changera et bien à ce moment là il ya
de beaux jours pour l'industrie textile
mais vous êtes plutôt bonnie and clyde
est enfin là et bien oui oui cette
évolution vers bonnie and clyde et bien
seront probablement bénéfique aux
victimes
il est possible que monsieur tiberghien
est un peu sous-estimé le chômage dans
le texas
non il licencié ils ont licencié de 110
brière jeudi sur notre malade je voulais
reprendre lui au chan a
commencé à licencier les ouvrières dont
j'étais obligé de toujours match j'étais
bobineuse et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
est bien la filature à fermer on a été
tout licencié
et quels salaires dus aux 55 milles par
mois et vous cherchez
on apporte qu'elle travaille pour vous
que je puisse le faire dans ce que
séverine nature vendeurs
dans le textile tourné par lala lala
pensez-vous pas du tout pas du tout
c'était déjà trop cherché plusieurs
métiers plusieurs usines pour avoir les
moyens possibles
nous avons visité les usines enfin le
faible partie des usines tiberghien à
linselles près de tourcoing
[Musique]
on s'aperçoit tout de suite du même
phénomène
modernisation
évidemment une industrie difficile un
travail difficile avec des salaires à
ses pas voilà par exemple un exemple
mode et de modernisation
cinq métiers pour ce que l'on nomme
leurs tournages
qui sont remplacés par cette machine
elle est entièrement commandé par un
programmateur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on croit toujours que le nord est
essentiellement uniquement industriels
on oublie que c'est aussi une vaste
région agricole à haut rendement qui
produit 7 % de la production nationale
de blé 13% de la production de pommes de
terre entre
nous avons rencontré un exploitant à
lille chez declémy l'agriculture dans la
région nord pas de calais comment ça
marche
le mieux à la situation s'est tout même
depuis quelques années notamment
améliorer
surtout pour ce qui est des séries à
mousse qui est de la betram vous avez
aussi un problème de reconversion dans
l'agriculture il a surtout dans cette
région pour le noir conversion dans les
structures quelle est la moyenne des
exploitations
dans cette région la voix de
l'exploitation doute être deux entre 20
et 60 hectares et vous voudriez arriver
à peu près je pense que la rentabilité
bien qu' il soit difficile de déceler
exactement les critères d'une
exploitation rentable je pense qu'il
faut - atterrir à 100 120 hectares les
gens de lille roubaix tourcoing ça fait
un bon million de personnes leur salade
leurs carottes martin matte elles
viennent de hollande la production
maraîchère
production à vocation spéciale elle
utilise surtout beaucoup de malheurs
alors que dans nos exploitations cette
région nous cherchons justement le
minimum de maunder de par la
modernisation de nos exploitations vous
arrivez à quel taux
nous arrivons dans cette région on nous
doit nous recherchons la possibilité
d'arriver employés un homme 40 hectares
environ
vous même je crois sur les 50 hectares
restants en culture normal
j'approche de
personnes et demi trois personnes pour
bien faire
ramener cette exploitation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non que chaque jeune du monde ouvrier
puisse continuer ses débuts jusqu'aux
examens
acquérir une qualification
professionnelle
exercer la profession qui correspond à
son choix à ses aptitudes avec un
salaire des gens c'est cela le vrai
grand rival à la pré formation
professionnelle
[Applaudissements]
on repère dans le nord 40% de la
population a moins de 20 ans
ces enfants 18 ans
le pointage pour le chômage
bocquillon
quel âge seulement
provient de tan tan chômage j'ai trois
mois
vous avez un vrai que je vous ai commis
tués
comme certificat son certificat d'études
se battre à fond
dans quoi vous étiez avant
l'école non à l'école j'ai jamais
travaillé encore merci
c'est la nuit qu'on monte en chômage
trois semaines et commencer à travailler
à quel âge
pourquoi je peux encore travailler
encore travailler d'un certificat de
l'aptitude quelque chose dans quoi
chercher mécanicien mécanique
merci
si c'est toi
juste enrichi morte et do c'est quoi ça
c'est dans l'entreprise de quoi départ
pas par un chômage depuis combien de
temps un an
et couvrir je suis guéri par mois j'ai
peu qu'on y touche et
je dois dire qu'elle a car metz de
béthune c'était comme une bouffée d'air
[Musique]
cette école allez les bleus à paris mais
pour travailler et renvoyée vous allez
rester ici en jeu puis par région
pourquoi ne pas beaucoup d'usinés
électricien
l'expression sur tille vtt mais c'est
tout de se déclarer sur mesure les plus
courageux sous le tri et la traiter à
trier à quel âge peut-on en attendre
et il ya du travail
je suis rentré
en iran
président du comité d'expansion c'est
pas tout à fait ordinaire ça non ça a
étonné aussi de ceux présents dans le
public lorsqu'il est venu à lille mais
n'est pas étonnant car hector étudie les
problèmes économiques de sa région en
plus il n'a aucun intérêt donc aucune
affaire c'est un véritable médiateur en
geek dans notre région le taux de
scolarisation est un des plus bas de
france faut pas exagérer
le tout sous arrestation n'est pas très
élevé par rapport à d'autres régions de
france il n'est certainement pas un des
plus bas surtout en
1967-68 après les efforts que nous avons
faits est-ce que vous pouvez le situer
ce taux bien ce taux à l'heure actuelle
sur 90 j'aurais département nous sommes
prêts 60e
saito
pourquoi bien c'est très facile expliqué
il faut reconnaître que pendant
longtemps il n'a pas été nécessaire dans
cette région de s'instruire dans tous
les milieux mais dans tous les milieux
que ce soit les milieux ouvriers qu'ils
sentaient pas d'insister de l'étude
puisqu'il y avait des emplois et que ces
zapa de n'exiger par une formation même
professionnel parle même pas de culture
et sur le plongerait patronales
n'étaient pas non plus nécessaire de
faire des études très poussées monsieur
le recteur pour la situation actuelle et
par brillante donc point de vue social
on ne peut pas dire que les brillantes
là qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour en
sortir eh bien je pense qu'il faut
changer la mentalité cette région la
psychologie de cette région et puis il
faut en plus que les familles
comprennent que c'est fini le temps du
ca paix et du certificat d'études qu'à
l'heure actuelle il faut absolument pour
le bonheur même des enfants 22 parler
l'expansion économique de cette région
il faut que ces enfants fassent des
études et des études n'ont pas
quelconque les études supérieures c'est
par les écoles d'ingénieurs c'est par
les techniciens c'est en développant nos
laboratoires et nos facultés que nous
allons lutter contre cette décadence
progressive de la région il n'y a pas de
possibilités aujourd'hui sans la matière
grise c'est le potentiel des cerveaux
qui est important pour l'expansion
économique mais et c'est cela qu'il faut
faire comprendre la région
mena
la cité scientifique
ana c'était le rêve de 1956 c'était
l'élément moteur d'une expansion qui
n'aurait jamais dû s'arrêter parce qu'un
abcès le creuset où devaient se former
tous les hommes qui aujourd'hui
servirait la cause économique de la
région aujourd'hui je puis dire que dans
tous les milieux on a compris que
annappes nous donnerait non seulement
des professeurs et des chercheurs des
ingénieurs des techniciens des sommes de
laboratoire car désormais la puissance
d'une région ne se trouve plus dans ses
usines mais dans ces amphithéâtres ses
laboratoires
non réfléchie
mais ce qu aux étudiants on trouve des
débouchés dans la région bien
difficilement parce que il ya encore un
gros effort à faire sur le plan des
employeurs pour leur faire comprendre
que dans cette bataille économique qui
est la nôtre il faut prendre des hommes
aux demandes qualifiées
j'ai le plus grand respect pour la
course paris roubaix mais il faut
reconnaître qu'avec sa légende des pavés
du nord de l'enfer du nord elles
faussent les esprits le nord ce n'est
pas des pavés et des corps
2 mais ici en pleine région minière
entre bruay et noeux les mines eh bien
c'est la campagne et les terrils sont
dans les champs
et ce petit village de rhuys n'a rien de
l'ubs là sa place là sont l'église
seulement un kilomètre du cimetière il y
à la fosse 6 de bruay
[Musique]
un rhuys vis des mineurs mais également
des pays d'accord votre famille vous
êtes tous cultivateurs non il ya deux
l'iac mondial de foot amateur mon frère
est parti
comme mineur oui mais les mines alors qu
est-ce qu est ce qu on fait ça car
chacun son petit chacun oui
un jour d'aujourd'hui fois cosmopolite
comme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non le nord n'est pas le peignoir
d'aller au fond cette région devrait
changer de nom on ne dit pas je vais
dans le sud on dit je vais dans le midi
à propos ces images ont été filmées le
27 mars à malo les bains
à l'horizon dunkerque
non le nord népalais et il a d'autres
atouts d'ailleurs pour l'avenir d'abord
la métropole c'est à dire l'ensemble
lille roubaix tourcoing
il y à là près d'un million de personnes
une vie active et qui représente un
énorme marché de consommation et
production et ça n'est pas d'ailleurs
une mince réussite vu les
particularismes entre ville d'avoir
réussi à réunir lille à roubaix
tourcoing autrement que par le célèbre
petit tramway on l'appelle le mongy
est d'arriver enfin à réunir dans ce
bâtiment les 83 communes des trois
villes la métropole existe réellement
[Musique]
un autre atout l'autoroute paris lille
ce n'est pas seulement une amélioration
pour la circulation
faut le dire c'est un changement de
mentalité lille à deux heures de paris
[Musique]
ce qui manque encore c'est l'autre axe
est ouest de maubeuge à dunkerque
l'interdît voici un cargo beaucoup
changé elle construit d'immenses
installations portuaires comme cette
grande écluse prévu pour les pétroliers
de 25000 225 pardon le 125 mille tonnes
et surtout dans le proche avenir la
construction de son avant port pétrolier
géant qui iront jusqu'à 300 mille tonnes
dunkerque devient le poumon de la région
du nord
avec le départ du canal du fameux canal
1350 tonnes dunkerque valenciennes qui
irriguera ces industries nouvelles que
tout le monde réclame dans le pays
[Musique]
ces industries nouvelles elles en sont à
leurs débuts il faut le dire ici la zone
de douvrin n'est encore qu'un projet
[Musique]
à béthune par contre les implantations
ont commencé fin aston installer une
usine de pneus et même sa direction et
ses cadres benotto encore et d'autres
c'est un commencement mais c'est le
commencement la mouvement
[Musique]
la région possède maintenant son
commissaire à la conversion industrielle
qui recherchent et organise ses
implantations d'industrie nouvelle
monsieur bicoque c'est un homme très
dynamique
monsieur viléo que vous dites que vous
allez remettre la région sur pied en
trois ans à la goutte et remettre la
région sur pied en trois ans et à gérer
ce que je crois c'est que dans les trois
ans qui viennent dans les années 70 71
feront
sur la pente montante
ce pays est extrêmement bien placé
à l'ouest de l'europe des six et
peut-être demain de l'europe des dix
rondes et 7 des 8 ou 10 x si vous
regardez une carte vous vous apercevez
que si vous prenez une pointe de confort
et que vous la mettiez à lille et que
vous ouvriez se compare sur 250 km vous
avez 60 millions d'armes vous avez
londres vous avez rotterdam possède bien
entendu vous avez la route et vous avez
tout bassin parisien on parle d'une au
charbon acier textile tout ça en
reconversion en restructuration
problèmes gigantesques mais on oublie
qu'il ya des industries ci qui marche
très bien on oublie ce que nous avons
dans la région des papeteries des
vergers qui sont mondialement connues
que nous avons des industries
alimentaires est à nantes que nous avons
par exemple j'ai découvert moi même une
affaire qui exporte 50 % de ses
fabrications à destination de
l'allemagne à des clients aussi
difficile à avoir que par exemple le
telefunken et ce sont des gens qui me
disent qu'ils ne disent rien par
modestie il faut faire comprendre aux
gens du nord qu'ils ont quelque chose
d'extraordinaire de vente
quitte à faire des efforts j'en conviens
et faire comprendre à l'extérieur du
nord que cette région n'est pas du tout
fichu comme on veut bien le dire dans
certains milieux avec ce potentiel
humain avec cette situation géographique
avec 7 avec cette tradition industrielle
on va pas me faire croire qu'on va
rester les bras ballants ça n'est pas
pensable
et c'est pour ça que je crois que
ce qui a été fait dans un livre blanc
qui est en train de circuler
et que l'oréal a à mon avis très bien
établie c'est que il donne une vision de
cette région à l'an 2000 on dit oui
travail à l'an 2000 mais savez-vous une
chose la ruhr dispose depuis 1925 d'un
plan à long terme et la reconversion
actuellement notamment des mines de
charbon et d'autres industries de la
ruhr se fait beaucoup plus facilement
grâce à ce plan qui a prévu les percées
les futures autoroutes qui a prévu les
espaces verts qui a prévu un urbanisme
convenable c'est pour ça que
personnellement je tire mon chapeau aux
jeunes lauréats d'avoir fait un papier
qui redonne une ambition à la région
pour les 40 ans qui nous séparent grosso
modo de l'an 2000 celle ci c'est
important comme tout pour les jeunes qui
viennent derrière alors dans les trois
ans qui viennent nous ont remonté la
pente à la région et après elle suivra
son cours le mouvement sera enclenchée
il commence à s'enclencher nous sentons
le nord bouge en ce moment les gens se
posent des questions des visiteurs
viennent nous voir je vous donne un
exemple des américains sont venus
installer en france et en europe ils
sont venus visiter la région au mois de
juin dernier ils ont été stupéfiés de
voir ce qu'il y avait comme commencement
de réalisation et quand on leur a monté
la projection dans l'avenir de ses
réalisations ils ont dit y a pas de
question le nord est gagnant en 2000
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non non 2000 d'accord une an prochain
[Musique]